[Music]
you gotta let me out of here oh okay
[Music]
you tricked me I can honestly say I
wasn't trying to trick you you weren't
all I said was you gotta let me out of
here there's no trick so it's right I do
have to let you out of here yes okay
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm where
order to let him go I don't know why
he's in there in the first place out
there
[Applause]
well you really got me in trouble
sorry yeah you must think I'm stupid
well I'm not stupid I'm smart so yeah
you know how you can prove that you're
really smart oh yeah let me guess you
want me to let you out of here again
well you know what you think you can
trick me into letting you out again
well you can't cuz this is my choice get
the heck out all right
all right reverse psychology
I'm sorry about that guys
that was me guys my bad my bad
real nice now this is they're gonna dock
my pain if I let you out of here again
I'm gonna be severely punished I don't
know I'm actually surprised they haven't
already thrown you in here with me no
prison is for bad guys you're a bad guy
and I'm a good guy yeah but you can see
how from my perspective I'm a good guy
wait you're a good guy oh my god it
doesn't seem like you understand what
your job is okay I see what you're doing
you're trying out you're trying to
manipulate me with reverse psychology
well it's not gonna work it's not even
worth going out there look they just
don't get me and bring me back in here
just like they always do unless what
no forget it I don't want to take
advantage me look hey let me listen I'm
not gonna fall for it
whatever it is it may as well just tell
me I was just gonna say that like if you
were to help me uh-huh
get past the guard yeah and all the way
out okay I really not have to tell you
you need to think about this long and
hard weigh your options and consider the
ramifications of those options like heck
I will don't yell man plus we'll bring
you long
oh yeah oh boy I did it again that's a
prison guard I wasn't allowed to talk to
prisoners that was the thing they said
to me if you talk to those prisoners
getting in trouble
[Music]
you
[Music]
you